shipwrights used the shell first method
in which the entire outer shell of
planking was built first and then
interior frames were added subsequently
to create the shell the individual
planks were attached to each other along
their edges in the earliest shell first
ships built in Egypt in the third
millennium BC the planks were actually
sewn together with linen cord as this
model illustrates but later as the
structural demands on hulls increased
this lacing was replaced by wooden
mortise and tenon joints what are they
well let's see how they were built going
to actually go through the process of
creating some mortise and tenon joints
in much the same way that an ancient
shipwright would do for a shell first
ship hull the way this process began was
that the shipwright would cut several
planks to the appropriate size and shape
like these and then would use a chisel
to chop rectangular slots indicated here
here here and here into the edges of
those planks notice that the rectangular
slots are carved into the top edge of a
lower plank and also into the bottom
edge of the plank that's going to be
placed directly above it into those
slots we will insert hardwood
rectangular blocks which are called
Tenon's Tenon's are inserted into the
mortises like this and then those
mortise and tenon connections are used
as the basis for attaching two
successive planks together like this
of course the two plates aren't really
attached together yet because I could
quite easily pull them apart so in order
to lock the joint together we're now
going to drill a hole through each of
the mortise and tenon joints and then
insert plugs or dowels to hold those
joints fast now I would love to
demonstrate the incredibly clever hand
drill that was used by ancient
shipwrights to do this sort of drilling
by for the sake of time I'm going to
have to resort to something a bit more
modern
my power drill the basic principle is
the same though regardless of the type
of drill that's that's going to be used
so I'm going to drill eight holes to
through each of the mortise and tenon
joints like this and then once again to
lock the joints in place we need to
insert these hardwood plugs into the
holes we've just drilled and I'll tap
them into place with a hammer and now
the two planks are very tightly and
rigidly attached together it's
impossible to pull them apart or to
slide them with respect to each other
it's really an incredibly effective
structurally efficient joint but of
course recall that that process would
need to be repeated many thousands of
times to create all the joints necessary
to build an entire Hall the joint was
incredibly effective many ship ranks of
shell first hulls actually show no
evidence whatsoever of any talking
between the individual planks a good
indicator that the method produced
extremely tight-fitting structural
joints given that caulking was not
required to seal them here we see a
museum reconstruction of the hyena ships
shell first hull note that the small
wooden frames have been added to the
inside of the shell to strengthen and
stiffen it but unlike the robust frames
used in the plank on frame system these
are lightweight secondary elements that
only extend across four or five planks
each the principal source of strength in
a shell first hull is the shell itself
one of the ways we know that these
frames weren't added until after the
ship was built is this stone relief
which shows a Roman ship right
fabricating a frame for a shell that has
already been fully constructed